I'm a very aesthetic person.
So, I'm very visual.
I definitely always cared about style.
I started working in design when I was 21 and never looked back.
It was one of the best decisions I've ever made, I really love it.
I'm only 30 but I've been doing it for nine years.
Sometimes people are surprised.
I love working with different craftsmen and architects and contractors,...
...and we've always had a good relationship.
Yeah, the first meeting can be intimidating.
If I'm going to meet with someone for the first time,...
...I like to put on a professional and polished outfit.
It just helps me feel more confident.
I'm ready to meet someone new and I'm ready to make a good first impression.
I think hopefully it helps them see that I'm not too young for the job.
I'm a big fan of wrap dresses.
They're professional, they're put together, all in one fell swoop.
What is so me?
So me is just probably, I mean the idea of not taking my style on dressing too seriously.
Not spending hours getting ready in the morning,...
...not meticulously picking everything out.
What I hope it looks like is kind of effortlessly chic.
Just pulling the pieces together quickly and having them represent you well.